mir nun zugeschaltet aus dem erzgebirge
der ehemalige skispringer und hotelier
jens weißflog ja hallo wir stehen hier
mit jens weißflog der seit 22 jahren im
erzgebirge ein apartment hotel mit
gastronomie führt und ihn betrifft das
natürlich besonders haben der andere
weniger
ja ich gebe mal kurz wie ist ihre
aktuelle situation aktuelle situation
ist ja noch in ordnung aber mit dem
bevorstehenden lockt darin sehe ich uns
natürlich ein gewisser maßen bisher in
sippenhaft genommen für dinge die wir
eigentlich nicht angetrieben haben das
heißt gastronomie hotellerie hier ist
ein bis zwei prozent am inn am
infizierung skat oder am infizierung
geschehen beteiligt und
wenn wir jetzt den dritten monat zu
machen würden vorausgesetzt es wird
einen monat geschlossen haben wir ein
vierteljahr dass der ist ja auch
ausgeschlossen
das heißt ein völlig anderes
jedes jahr ist keine umsätze das heißt
natürlich auch wieder die leute entweder
in kurzarbeit schicken oder die die
kosten weiterhin tragen haben
im früheren kredit aufnehmen müssen um
die kosten überhaupt weiter bezahlen zu
können und es wäre für viele gläubige
des sturms insgesamt in der branche
sie haben wir auch gesagt sie fühlen
sich ein bisschen an den pranger
gestellt als gastronom und hotelier sie
werden immer in den nachrichten zuerst
genannt bekommen so erzählen sie mal
wenn wir das nachrichtengeschehen
verfolgt wird gastronomie und
veranstaltungswesen immer als erstes
genannt
und da sehe ich uns bisher in sippenhaft
genommen für vier branchen dir weit mehr
zum infizierung des geschehens beitragen
als die gastronomie selbst wir haben mit
tisch abständen mit plexiglas wänden mit
vielen dingen dafür gesorgt dass diese
dinge nicht passieren und jetzt wird
soll wieder zugemacht werden wo die
branche sowieso schuldenprobleme hat
auch was arbeitskräfte betrifft wenn
immer branchen zuerst zugemacht werden
haben wir natürlich auch die befürchtung
dass arbeitskräfte abwandern in andere
branchen mode wo das ein problem nicht
so stark stritt also die lage hier aus
dem erzgebirge vom mehrfachen
olympiasieger jens weißflog der jetzt
ein apartment hotel betreibt dem geht es
also nicht gut und ein weiterer lockt
wird der katastrophe seien also er
bekommt auch hat schon kredite beantragt
amos kritiker tanga bekommt keine hilfe
weil ab was sagten sie ab elf
angestellten bekommt man eben einfach
keine hilfe sondern muss kredite ab und
jetzt die dann abstottern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren